and on book TVs afterwards program at
9:00 p.m. Eastern sylvia tara discusses
the history and science behind body fat
at 10:00 Doug Wead discusses his book
game of thorns which looks at why the
Clinton campaign lost the 2016
presidential election the winning
strategy of the Trump campaign and
president Trump's plan to move America
forward and to wrap up our Sunday
primetime lineup at 11:15
journalists and civil rights attorney
alia Malik talks about the lives and
struggles of a collection of people
Muslims Christians Jews Armenians and
Kurds who are living in her
grandmother's apartment building in
Damascus Syria that all happens tonight
on c-span two's book TV
marine doubt how do you view your job
Wow Peter that's a big question I don't
like to talk about this because it
sounds a little corny I view my job as a
watchdog and Times readers often don't
understand that I'm not an ideological
columnist I'm not coming from the left
or the right I I was a political
reporter for 20 years and so I come at
it more from a political reporting point
of view I'm just gonna try and tell them
I'm gonna it's like Toto pulling the
curtain in The Wizard of Oz I'm gonna
try and give our readers anything I can
find out that they need to know about
you know what is true and what is false
and what these people are going to have
life-and-death power over us are really
like and where they're lying and where
they're you know rising to the occasion
and Marine dads most recent book is
called the year of voting dangerously
the derangement of American politics how
many US presidents have you covered do
you know well I started I covered the
very tail end of Reagan when he was on
his way out I did a few features on him
and actually I went on a trip with him
to an Asian economic summit and covered
Nancy because in those days if you were
the woman you covered the woman so I
covered Nancy Reagan a bit I did an
interview with her where I fail to ask
the most of her the most important
question but I failed to get the right
answer which was are you superstitious
and she said a little and knocked on on
wood but it was really Formica in the
plane we were in and then it turned out
she was running the entire Russia
relationship with her astrologer
deciding everything about whether we
would you know have nuclear arms
reduction so I kind of missed the big
story there but I started there and then
I was the White House reporter for the
first president Bush and a little a year
with President Clinton
and then I got a column in 95 but I kept
covering presidents well you suggest in
the year of voting dangerously that you
and president HW senior should have
couples Council no I think his aide
suggested that the wonderful Jeanne
Beker it is like a screwball comedy I
wrote an essay in the book that I'm
really proud of an original essay about
my thirty years you know covering the
Bush family and the letters that the
first President Bush has written me over
the years I put in the essay and it's a
very unusual relationship because he
wasn't
he's like a wasp from Greenwich who was
taken to kindergarten in a chauffeured
limousine and I obviously I'm from a
working-class ethnic background and I
think he was expecting the New York
Times reporter to be like Clyde
Farnsworth the third and they would have
martinis and discuss the Atlantic
Alliance and you know he got something
quite different but we came to
appreciate each other over the years and
he represents the kind of civility that
may be gone from our politics for good
he sent you literally hundreds of notes
yes he did and you know as he himself
says these are not notes that would be
like John Adams or Thomas Jefferson
letters where historians would mine them
you know they're more kind of fun notes
complaining about the lives that the New
York Times and who he likes and who he
doesn't and trying to get me to be more
conservative and listened to my
conservative siblings and it's all about
what he calls our love-hate relationship
but he's really not a hater so he's you
know but he has a really wacky sense of
humor I would compare him to Tom Hanks
and in in Big where he is like a boy
bursting out of an adult body and when
he was the ambassador to China he or the
representative in China the Chinese used
to say
he had a personality like ants on a hot
pan just very I mean he's the opposite
of low-energy Jeb JEB should have had
some of that energy
well marine doubt is our guest and if
you'd like to call in and talk to her
the numbers are on the screen 2:02
is the area code 7 for 8 8200 for those
of you in the east and central time
zones two zero two seven four eight
eight two zero one if you live in the
mountain and Pacific time zones we'll
get to those in just a minute what's
your relationship what was your
relationship with george w bush it was
it was good in the beginning I had an
interview with him when he first
announced up in the Kennebunkport
compound and he liked me because I had
given Barbara Bush a good review in the
New York Times for her memoir which was
really fun you know
Barbara's very sort of fiery Greenwich
granite Peggy Noonan called her and so
it was fine at first but then
unfortunately I think he went down a
very bad path with a rock and came under
the sway of the man I first I think I
was the first to dub Dick Cheney Darth
Vader although then he began calling
himself that very proudly and now Steve
Bannon calls himself that so I think the
relationship with all the press corps
got more tense as they kind of you know
had fake news about the Iraq war marine
down in November of 2008 and this is in
the book the year of voting dangerously
you write about the White House how can
such a lovely house make so many of its
inhabitants nuts right well this is you
know a lot of my friends are really
hysterical about the Trump presidency
and one of my girlfriend's suits a
health nut free to be missed she lives
in San Francisco she said to me oh my
gosh you know I'm I'm having a glass of
wine a day now and I try to reassure
them and say don't worry you know we've
had a lot of crazy presidents in modern
history and Lyndon Johnson's aides used
to argue about whether he was a
manic-depressive or a clinically
paranoid you know JFK and Nixon took
psychotropic drugs and so yes the
presidents at the very moment where they
should feel affirmed and confident that
the American public has put them in the
seat of power often you know they're
gremlins their insecurities come out
instead and so you know Nixon was
walking the halls talking to the
paintings and doing a lot of crazy
things and so Watergate so yes you know
we've had we've survived a lot of crazy
presidents already so of course we're
going to survive one more do you think
Donald Trump can quote unquote drain the
swamp or change Washington culture I
think it's up in the air you know he he
has a point in a lot of people sort of
from the swamp but it remains to be seen
whether like Joe Kennedy you know they
appointed Joe Kennedy to the Securities
and Exchange Commission because he was
the Fox in the henhouse he knew that he
knew because he had you know broken the
rules himself how to catch people
breaking the rules
so like the best hope is that that's
what's happening with Trump's appointees
that because they know this they will
help you know figure it out but you know
I don't
I wouldn't sanguine Li say that I expect
that to happen I'm just saying we're not
sure yet marine doubt in your Kalos you
expose a lot of yourself and your family
in there don't you yeah I do
because I call them my little basket of
deplorable because I come from a
conservative family and you know my
father stayed up all night the night
Truman was elected he was so excited he
worked in the Senate he was a police
detective and you know he knew Truman
and loved him and so my parents were up
all night excited about Truman on the
night Trump won my brother was up all
night excited about Trump so the
Democrats have to figure out how they
lost you know the working-class ethnic
vote and what they can do to get it back
your sister Peggy Dowd has a has a
chapter in your book she does this is
the first time she's written I let my
brother write the column once a year
because I think it's really good I think
New York Times readers really enjoy
getting in the belly of the red-state
beast you know and hearing how they
think
I think liberals are better about
hearing how conservatives things and
conservatives just want to hear
themselves echoed endlessly and so I
asked my sister to write an essay
because she has an amazing political
history she was at JFK's inauguration
because she loved JFK she wasn't even
old enough to vote yet she was 18 and
then she her can you vote at 18 not not
back then I don't know I think that
happened they changed that all right so
then she she loved Bobby Kennedy and was
at the Ambassador Hotel the night he was
assassinated
and then she fell in love with w and
volunteered at his 2000 convention and
she didn't she couldn't get a room in
Philadelphia so she came to my room and
said could she stay with me and I said
you can come in but the sign that says W
stands for women cannot come in my work
and then she got disillusioned about the
Iraq war and decided to vote for Barack
Obama and then she got disillusioned
about President Obama and sort of
briefly became a socialist with Bernie
Sanders and then she went to Cuba and
fell in love with che guevara and became
a communist for a weekend and then she
decided she liked Trump so she has
historic historic thing where she got
the only apology that has ever issued
from Donald Trump's mouth because he
would always ask me when I was
interviewing him during the campaign is
your sister still with me and after he
retweeted the mean picture of Heidi Cruz
you know an unflattering picture
compared to Melania I said to him he
lost my sister she thinks that was
horrible and offensive and he there was
a long pause and he goes he tried to
explain himself and I said stop there's
no explanation for what you did and so I
said why don't you just apologize and he
goes okay I apologize
tell your sister Marie now the first
time you spoke truth to power like that
were you nervous oh I was terrified when
I was covering I still am I was covering
the first president Bush and my bosses
you know these tough nighttime press
conferences then and my bosses gave me
like a four-part arms control question
but I was too terrified to ask it so I
never asked a question at a press
conference or in a gaggle and finally
President Bush decided he was going to
ask me a question and oppressed but he
never did
yeah it's eerie but you know there's an
old saying a cat can look at a king so
you know we have to we're and which I
think people realize more than ever now
an important part of the democracy where
we are you know we are the ones who tell
people when politicians have become
drunk with power and are doing things
that can really hurt the country and I
take that role really seriously the Year
voting dangerous lead the derangement of
American politics is the newest book by
marine Dowd and Timothy is in West Palm
Beach Florida Timothy you're on book TV
with marine dad go ahead he's I came to
West Palm Beach for three years ago
retired from Washington I found that
very few people knew anything about till
winter blowers have to apologize and let
you go neither of us can understand what
you're saying it sounds like you're on a
speakerphone so let's move on to Robert
who's also in Florida in st. Petersburg
Robert we're listening hi I'm Maureen
I'm glad just glad to finally get you on
the phone I've been calling it his plan
for four years and I finally got through
I just wanted to ask your questions what
was the craziest first lady you ever met
here here um let me think about that for
a second
so you knew Nancy Reagan para Laura Bush
is lovely Nancy Reagan was a very
formidable woman she's you know as
somebody said Ronald Reagan you know
might have been pumping gas if it
weren't for Nancy Reagan she was a she
was a great politician as is Michelle
Obama you know because they're in such
an antiquated white satin box of a job
you know you often can't see how great a
politician they would be themselves and
Michelle Obama for instance was always
urging her husband to be more visceral
in the debates and in his response to
things which was great advice because he
would always fall into being very
cerebral and let me think what are their
firstly you have Barbara Bush in there
Barbara Bush is wonderful and I sent its
a Christmas present to the Bush's a few
years ago I sent a soundtrack to the
movie 50 shades of grey
that's the joke because Bush has a
President Bush it's a wonderful sense of
humor and Barbara Bush wrote me back and
note thanking me and she goes I haven't
read the book I really don't think you
know it's my cup of tea and you know as
I say Greenwich Greenwich and then who
else Hillary Clinton yeah Melania Trump
yeah Melania Trump is lovely you know I
met her in a 99 campaign trip with
Donald Trump when they were dating and I
think she has a very lovely very
reserved aura about her and I think if
she doesn't want to come to Washington
everyone should leave her alone because
she's a wonderful mother and if that's
her priority that's great and it's a
super antiquated job anyway and people
in Washington are kind of like oh it's
going to do
the Easter egg hunt you know well I hate
to let you in on a secret but the first
lady is enough in a room dyeing Easter
eggs and weaving baskets I'm sure they
can handle that without her Hillary
Clinton well Hillary is half my book so
you should get the book because I start
covering her in 92 when she is chafing
at the very words first lady and she
wanted to be called First Mate which
sounds a little more like a pirate but
you can see in my stories and columns
through the years the evolution of how I
feel about her so I highly recommend my
own book there and you refer to the
White House during the Clinton time
there as motel 1600 well yeah I thought
it was very offensive the way donors you
know we're buying the Lincoln Bedroom
and Air Force One and I think that money
has always been you know that grass
penis has always been a problem for the
Clintons even now that they have like
230 million or whatever she still felt
the need to do six hundred seventy five
thousand worth of Goldman Sachs speeches
which is not I mean at that point it's a
psychological issue she just clearly
feels that they have to keep stockpiling
money maybe because she was the
breadwinner when they got started in
Arkansas James is calling in from Loon
Lake Washington James you're on book TV
with marine dad
well good day Maureen Dowd
[Applause]
during the program I feel like I walked
through a lookingglass software around
evening on November 8th and have
wondered what's been going on I'm in an
alternative reality all of a sudden and
you know there's a great deal of concern
regarding the amount of Russian
influence in our government for the
election and now how much is here to
stay
how much has integrated itself into the
fabric of our government machine because
a great deal of the important people
seem to be ignoring it totally they
refuse to ask thank you let's hear from
marine Dowd we've got looking-glass and
that's an election James I can't tell
you the number of times I've written the
words looking glass into a column and
then taking it out because I've used it
so often and you're right it's an
alternative universe and like bizarro
world with alternative facts and I have
to tell you that the Russian story is
the strangest thing that my colleagues
and I have seen in our careers it's
inexplicable and you know they're gonna
have to it's just strange to see the
Republicans twisting themselves into
pretzels to try and you know be aligned
with Donald Trump's position in this
bromance with pretty food as Bush used
to w used to call him that was his
nickname for him but w started out
thinking that he could see into Putin's
soul and as John McCain said the only
thing you see when you look into Putin's
solar the words KGB or letters KGB so I
think it is a bizarre bizarre a--world
situation with this relationship with
Putin and I think we're gonna have to
have investigations and get to the
bottom of Trump's relationship with the
Russians and his aides relationship with
the Russians and I agree with you 100%
do you hear from your readers i i am
super super sensitive believe it or not
so it's hard for me to read you know
they can be very tough fun times
columnist and it's funny because when i
let Kevon write my column he loves
reading the nasty comments he loves it
he frames them but it's hard for me I
think I would be just debilitated under
the pillows if I read all of them so I
don't I mean I I would love to hear what
times readers think if it was not
scatological or you know
obscene but as you know the Internet has
coarsened
his course and society and it
particularly hits women on the Internet
so it's best for me not to see all that
stuff well Peggy Dowd
wrote in her chapter in the book about
her convertible top being slashed
because she had a Goldwater sticker on
the car exactly that's exactly right and
things obviously have only gotten more
and more divisive to the point where
relationships are breaking off over
trough
you know siblings are not talking to
each other over Trump but I have been
used to my conservative family for so
long that were just used to each other
now the low point came during W because
I wrote seven years worth of columns
against the Iraq war and one time I came
to Thanksgiving and my older brother
Michael said to me you know if there was
a hurricane you'd blame it on W and then
there was Katrina and I did so I've
already been through low points now we
we just know each other
Craig is in Tulsa Oklahoma go ahead with
your question or comment from marine dad
Craig yes a pleasure to talk to you yeah
I just was looking at it from a
sociological point of view and I was
curious if you kind of examined it in
that way meaning this that you know I've
never been a person that supported any
kind of like throw man Pro women Pro
battle the sexes of any side I believe
in unity and people working together but
I think when Trump was elected and he
had to be elected by a lot of women as
well as men it seems like there was a
piece or a truce called in the sense of
saying not that men are in charge that's
not what Trump winning meant what it
meant was it's actually contrary to the
90s ideology it's actually okay for a
man to be strong and to lead it's like
it was it became okay now to be a man I
was curious sociologically what you
think of that
yeah Oh Craig well my second book is
about gender politics so I'm always
paying attention to that and you know I
think in a way President Trump doesn't
get enough credit because he's revived
all of these things that were sort of
phlegmatic he's revived feminism he's
revived liberalism he's revived the ACLU
he's put new life into journalism we
have an actual newspaper war now with
the times and the post and you know I
think I I got into politics covering
Geraldine Ferraro and they thought there
would be a big wave a feminist passion
that would help help the ticket and
there wasn't and I called a lot of women
afterwards and interviewed them for a
magazine piece and I think it's it's
just a mistake to think that women are
going to vote in a block like
african-americans do and young women
especially were a rude awakening to the
Clinton campaign we you know win
Madeleine Albright and Clarita Steinem
went out and was like you you owe it to
feminism to vote for Hillary and they
were like no we don't we're gonna vote
for the person we're not going to vote
you know for a woman because she's a
woman that what feminism was meant to
accomplish was exactly what these young
women were saying to give them the right
to vote for whoever they wanted to not
in identity politics so I would suggest
you get my last two books because one of
them is all about exactly what you're
talking about and you know that was the
funny thing about covering the campaign
because it was this like Billie Jean
King Bobby Riggs battle of the genders
because Trump was so almost like a
caricature of a macho man you knew you
just picture him coming out of a steam
room in Vegas with Frank Sinatra in 1959
you know and he had Mike Tyson and Don
King and all these macho former felt
like that's you know where his
celebrities and then Hillary because she
hadn't pushed gender in 2008 was really
pushing gender in this caricature way
where
everything was like a slump girl slumber
party with Lena Dunham and Katy Perry
and Ariana Grande music and so it did
make a funny gender contrast marine Dowd
previous books are called Bush world
enter at your own risk and our men
necessary when sexes collide she won the
Pulitzer in 1999 for commentary and her
most recent book is called the Year
voting dangerously on the cover is that
the famous escalator from June 2015 that
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton are
coming down
that's so funny yeah we did the
escalator the gilt escalator but then
when Theresa May came to visit Trump you
know when he held her hand it sort of
came out that he's scared of stairs so
but I guess he's not scared of stairs
where he doesn't have to move on that
but it's a funny image the escalator for
someone who's scared of stairs
Tina Hollidaysburg Pennsylvania good
afternoon
yes good afternoon I just noticed that
Maureen was saying something about how
nice Melania is and what a nice person
she is and yet she's not living in the
White House and she's okay with that
however I've been wondering if
Republicans and other people also would
feel that way if Michelle Obama would
have done that seeing that she had very
young young girl and if the next person
that gets in to the White House also had
a spouse who would just decide that's
not for me well you know there are a lot
of things that if the Obamas had done it
you know I don't think they would have
survived look at you know when Sarah
Palin's family came into that Convention
and you know her daughter was pregnant
and not married I mean you know the
Obamas had to be like Caesar's wife as
the first African Americans and Michelle
was very conscious of that and I think
she did a peerless job
having you know I went with the Obamas
to Cuba and I was very proud to travel
with them as the president and first
lady because they represent and those
girls are amazing and they represent in
America so well and I think Michelle
Obama did a virtually perfect job as
first lady and I think she knew as you
know Fox and everyone was saying that
her performance was equally important to
his in terms of how history would view
him and I think she was wonderful and I
agree with you that they were judged by
you know a very different narrow
standard and they were always conscious
of that and from the year of voting
dangerously marine down rights that
President Obama he made us feel good
about ourselves Michael in Yucca Valley
last call go ahead thank you to c-span
and missed down I have two things one it
seems to me that the we're all licking
our wounds after the election those of
us who are to the left it seems to me
that all the pundits are looking for the
answers as to how could this
how could domicile possibly get elected
I think in my mind the elephant room is
it was personality was his pizzazz it
was his celebrity nature was what people
today because of the median because of
our access to quick information and
instant solution the so they gravitate
towards his personality the Democrats
don't seem to see that that Hillary just
didn't have that dynamic personality and
maybe it seems to me and I'd like your
opinion don't don't the Democrats need
in 2020 a person with an incredible
personality like shares to win the
second thing at a time
I apologize we have to leave it go I
agree with you a thousand percent I
think the Democrats ignored that at
their own peril in this age you know you
can already see all these celebrities
like Oprah and Mark Cuban and maybe
George Clooney are sort of and Howard
Schultz are circling around
because they think aback I could do it I
could do it but I think the Democrats
oftentimes have nominated people with
hall monitor personalities like Al Gore
and Hillary and John Kerry and you know
people just couldn't warm up to them and
I think that was the margin of
difference and when you had a Bill
Clinton who had that big personality you
know that really helped him I agree with
you absolutely I don't know why they
never learned that lesson Maureen Dowd
first time taking calls on c-span
very much appreciated her most recent
book is the year of voting dangerously
the derangement of American politics you
can read her in the New York Times as
well we're on the banks of the Cape Fear
River and historic Wilmington North
Carolina coming up we'll sit down with
one Wilmington author who writes about
the US government led effort to save
thousands of Vietnamese children before
the fall of Saigon in 1975
operation baby lift was an evacuation of
two to three thousand Vietnamese
displaced children from Saigon at the
very end of the war there in April of
1975 the purpose of the baby lift was to
remove from Vietnam these several
thousand displaced children who were
considered orphans and therefore in need
of stable homes somewhere else and this
was right at the time when the war in
Vietnam which had lasted for thirty
years it had basically basically been
going on since 1945 in different forms
was about to end so in March of 1975 the
North Vietnamese began their their final
move into South Vietnam and within six
weeks this 30-year war really quickly
came to an end and there were a number
of small and larger adoption agencies in
Vietnam that were working with children
and preparing them for adoption and
these agencies decided at that point
when the North Vietnamese was about to
take over that they needed to expedite
those adoptions and get the children in
their care out of Vietnam as quickly as
possible and so with the help of the US
government they arranged an airlift and
they evacuated these children the United
States
left-left Vietnam are pulled out for the
most part in the early 1970s but it took
a while for it was the the war was still
kind of at a stalemate and so it wasn't
until March of 1975 that the that the
North finally began to make the moves
that ended up bringing the war to an end
and that was by moving south starting in
the Central Highlands and then sort of
slowly moving continuously south from
there and the South Vietnamese
government
made really bad choice to kind of pull
back when the north began this this
final kind of invasion and pull back and
try to fight in the area where they felt
most comfortable and what happened was
that caused a panic and so people in the
northern part of South Vietnam felt that
they had been abandoned by the South
Vietnamese government and they started
fleeing farther south and so you had you
had hundreds of thousands of people
fleeing one part of the country and
moving south tore towards the cut east
and south so toward the coast and then
south towards Saigon and I guess the
best way to describe what was going on
in that last six weeks of the war was
increasing chaos and panic and a lot of
South Vietnamese wanting to get out of
the country as well because they were
afraid of what was going to happen when
the Communists took over that point and
there was something like 800,000
displaced children in Vietnam so that's
a really really large number and that
was a result to a large extent of the
war and by displace I don't necessarily
mean that they were orphans but that
they were not able to be raised by their
parents when it became clear that the
South Vietnamese government was going to
collapse the adoption agency
administrators in Saigon understood that
this was going to be a crisis for their
agencies and for the children that they
were trying to send for adoption
overseas and many of these children had
been in the adoption pipeline as they
called it for months or years already
and they were just waiting because
adoption generally can take a long time
to process so they became concerned that
the children who were in their care were
not going to end up being able to go
overseas because the government will
collapse and that they would have to
leave them and be in
and they were worried about their what
would happen to them
and so they began to appeal to the US
government to help to remove these
children from the country and it took a
while and it took there was a there was
a man named Edie Daly who ran his own
private airlines I mean he he was his
airline was called World Airways and he
brought in a lot of military equipment
into Vietnam so he made a lot of money
in Vietnam but he also had some concern
about the children so he ended up flying
up to the very first plane load of
children who left Vietnam on operation
baby lift were actually airlifted out on
one of his planes I mean it was you
could say it was a big publicity stunt
you could say that he was doing it
because he was really concerned about
these children for whatever reason he
airlifted the first group and the US
government seeing that he had done this
on his own and that it was done in a way
that was not legally proper decided to
get involved and with that Gerald Ford
decided to begin a more organized
evacuation that was eventually called
Operation baby left or the wharf an
airlift the children who were being
adopted were for the most part going to
the United States although a significant
number went to Europe and also Australia
many if not most of them were already
scheduled to be adopted by families who
had been going through this process for
a while already but in the end
especially in the last few weeks I mean
anybody who's seen the photographs of
the very end of the war the fall of
Saigon and the helicopter on top of the
US government building people climbing
up to get in and just the complete chaos
at that time knows that nothing worked
in a really organized and efficient
manner and one of the results of that in
terms of the baby lift was that a lot of
parents at the very end of the war
Vietnamese parents were so panicked
about what was going to happen to
children after the Communists took over
that they did whatever they could to get
she'll get their children into these
adoption agencies and on these planes to
be adopted overseas even if it meant
giving up those children and their
ability to care for them and so a lot of
a lot of the children
maybe maybe 10 or 20 percent so not a
majority but a significant number sort
of ended up on these planes at the last
minute and they were not already in the
adoption pipeline and then by the time
they got to the US or the countries that
they ended up in there was a question of
where we gonna how how are we gonna
place these people these children and
where will we put them that sort of
thing
first u.s. sponsored plane that that was
dedicated towards the baby lift was a
galaxy aircraft which is a military
aircraft and it it came in to Vietnam on
April 4th and children were very quickly
loaded into the plane I think there were
two hundred and something children
loaded onto a big cargo jet so I mean
you know what the inside of a passenger
plane looks like it's got seats on it
but this was a cargo jet so most of it
the bottom part of it was like the
inside of a warehouse so there's no
seats there's there's no way to sort of
protect anybody that's on there but it
was it was such a moment of chaos and
and and concern about what was going to
happen that all the children were just
put onto the plane very quickly so there
were many older children on the bottom
of the plane in this cargo area plus the
caregivers who got on with them and then
in the top part of the plane which is
kind of a passenger area there were a
lot of infants and nurses and people who
were taking care of the sickest children
so a few minutes after that plane took
off the rear cargo door blew off there
was a big explosion
and the pilots were able to maintain
some control over the plane they turn
the plane around there's their
testimonies from from people who were on
the top part of the plane who tell us
what happened what it was like inside
the plane the fear that they felt they
were out over the the water over the
ocean at that time the pilots were
incredible and they were able to turn
the plane around and try to get back to
Saigon but they couldn't make it back to
Saigon and the plane crashed in the rice
fields outside of Saigon we don't even
know how many people were killed because
we don't know how many people were
actually on the plane as I said
everything was done in such a
disorganized rushed way that and then a
lot of the papers were destroyed that
it's hard to know there were children
who survived up above but on the in the
cargo area I think almost everybody was
killed so that was um it was like one
heartbreak following so many years of
heartbreak already and so there was a
question briefly about whether or not
the baby lift would continue but the
President Gerald Ford said we're gonna
keep going operation baby lift lasted
from for about three weeks in maybe I
should say a month in in April of 1975
and when Saigon fell there were no more
planes leaving leaving Vietnam with
children in them so it was a very short
time in a very intense time and during
that period something between two and
three thousand children were evacuated
following the baby lift and and the fall
of Saigon in the months that the months
after that a group of lawyers filed a
class-action lawsuit on behalf of these
children just to slow down the process
of the adoptions and make sure that all
the children who were being adopted were
legally eligible for adoption under the
terms of the Geneva Accord
and that lawsuit was eventually thrown
out because more for legal reasons than
on the merits of the case because the
judge decided that that these these
children didn't serve as a class which a
class action lawsuit everybody has to
have suffered in the same way anyway
there were individual lawsuits though
that that did go through and these were
mostly based on birth parents who gave
up their children at the very end of the
war
mostly birth mothers and then they
managed to get out of Vietnam themselves
and get to the United States as refugees
and when they got to the United States
they looked for their children and they
when they found them there were certain
situations where the adoptive families
had had the children for months or maybe
even a year and the birth parents filed
to regain custody of their children
saying that they had to give them up
under duress and those lawsuits played
out and a number of those there were
there was maybe less than ten I think
those lawsuits generally ended with the
birth parents
receiving custody of their children
again but they were very complicated and
difficult for the most part adoptive
families ended up raising these children
I actually been doing research for a new
book on the refugee situation in in in
Europe and the Middle East and it's been
very interesting to be learning about
that in the context of what happened
during Operation baby left because there
is very very little talk about adoption
now the the discussion of refugees
focuses on keeping families together if
there are orphans and there are orphans
unfortunately there seem to be real
serious efforts to find them family
somewhere a lot of times these families
who are fleeing Syria for example
already have some family members who are
living in Europe and so a lot of times
those orphans will end up go
to live with aunts and uncles and
cousins and grandparents in countries in
Europe so I think that I'm not saying
that they're directly thinking of
operation baby lifts when they think
about this policy but I think that a lot
has changed in the decades since the
baby lift and that public policy makers
and humanitarian agencies and probably
adoption agencies as well are making an
effort to really do their homework and
not be pressed by chaos to rush into
anything even there was a there was an
earthquake in Haiti a few years ago and
there were some children there who were
in the process of being adopted by
American families and those children
because the situation in Haiti was so
bad those children were airlifted out of
Haiti and brought to I think
Pennsylvania and the adoption agency
made some effort to just expedite the
adoption so that the children could go
into the families that they were
supposed to be adopted with quicker and
the US government said no we are not
speeding up the process of adoption just
because of what happened there's still
things that need to be done to make sure
that this is appropriate and I think
that's great I want people who read this
book to understand that these issues of
what happens to children and their
families are really complicated they are
they can't be solved easily but that
with time we can get there and we need
to do that for the children so that we
don't make mistakes that can't really be
remedied later
see spam where history unfolds daily in
1979 c-span was created as a public
service by America's cable television
companies and is brought to you today by
your cable or satellite provider
hello there Schaumburg family how are
you doing this evening thank you good
evening and welcome to the Schomburg
Center for research in black culture my
name is novella Ford and I manage public
programs here at the Schaumburg thank
you for joining us for tonight's between
the lines featuring author Adrienne
Miller in his most recent book the
president's kitchen cabinet the story of
the African Americans who have fed our
first families from the Washington's to
the Obamas as we saw in the video the
Schomburg Center is a one-of-a-kind
research institution that's dedicated to
the collection preservation and
interpretation of the global black
experience also you may have heard in
January the Schomburg Center was named a
National Historic Landmark by the
National Park Service so they know what
you all know the landmark status
recognizes its vast collection of
materials that represent the history and
culture of people of African descent
through the global transnational
perspective and through public programs
our exhibitions film screenings
performances engaging conversations like
the one we're sure to have today we
explore the historical and contemporary
narratives that continue to shape our
nation in our world also we hope through
public programs that you are able to
explore our archival collection which
boasts over 10 million items so
certainly come here for our public
programs but then go and visit one of
our five divisions where you can find
rare books photographs other kinds of
collections and and other resources so I
would tell you about the rest of the
programs for February but since its
Black History Month every month here at
the Schomburg Center I'm gonna tell you
about Black History Month in March next
month we are featuring our women's Jazz
Festival ella ella a centennial
celebration of mama jazz this year we
will feature an evening discussing the
legacy of Ella Fitzgerald and three
nights of Ella Fitzgerald inspire
performances by some of the most
well-known and emerging women in jazz
today this event and others can be found
on the Schomburg website Schomburg
Center org as well as through Eventbrite
by searching Schomburg also you can find
it in our winter program brochure which
is also located in the LA
I want to say thank you to any Schomburg
society members that we have here your
support yes okay your support makes it
possible for us to deliver consistent
high-caliber programming for the low
cost of free to the public all year
around before we turn to tonight's
program I'm going to ask everyone to
silence your cellphone's also no flash
photography or a video and before we get
started before I have a chance to
introduce you to our panelists I want to
bring out Kevin young the director of
the Schomburg Center we're very excited
to have Adrian here and to have you all
here it's a good-looking crowd out there
novella told you all the good news that
we have national historic landmark
status which we're delighted by we have
the black power show up right now and
we're almost done with our renovation
which has been going on over a year and
we really are excited for the new spaces
and to have you come warm them up with
us there was a moment ago that I was
gonna maybe be come out here and say I
am Tanya Hopkins and and conduct some of
the interview with Adrian who I've known
a while and has a brilliant food writer
the soul food scholar but I'm gonna turn
over the stage to Adrian and Tanya and
welcome again thank you so let me
introduce you to our panelists
Adrian Miller is a recovering lawyer who
worked as a special assistant to
President Bill Clinton we all know some
of those right today he's a culinary
historian who has lectured around the
country Adrian's first book soul food
the surprising story of an American
cuisine one play at a time was published
in August of 2013
soul food won the 2014 James Beard
Foundation Book Award for reference and
scholarship his second book the one
featured tonight the president's kitchen
cabinet
and it stops right there sorry he is a
certified Kansas City barbecue society
judge in a former southern foodways
Alliance board member leading us through
tonight's conversation is Tonya Hopkins
whose career began in marketing as a
qualitative researcher and brand
strategist for various brands including
food wine and premium spirits brands
these experiences filled her unique
perspective on ethnic and mainstream
American food cultures and led her to
found thought Co Consulting and
commentary on all things culinary and
cultural and more recently the food
griot a multimedia platform through
which she also provides historic and
contemporary culinary consulting and
consulting and content narrated historic
dinners tastings and events as
co-founder of the non-profit James
Hemings foundati Tonya serves as a food
historian agree oh and a William in a
wine specialist for historically
inspired dinners including the June 2016
James Beard House event based on the
historically famous 1790 reconciliation
dinner a lavish meal prepared by Thomas
Jefferson's enslaved french-trained chef
James Hemings who helps up the table for
America's future
please welcome Adrienne Miller and Tonya
Hopkins
[Applause]
daddy knows me in my bags security
Adrian what's up oh yeah well time no
see right I know it's been a while it's
been a minute yeah first time I met this
brother y'all was at a southern foodways
conference where was it it was um oh
wait a minute what's the P oh yeah I
don't remember I don't recall you don't
remember when I tell this I know why he
tells the story I'm all excited I think
it was my first one it was I don't know
15 years ago and I'm like oh what's this
probably gonna talk about and he gets up
me tells the story about the long-lost
delicacy of possum that's right I was
like what is he talking about
and but turns out that was great and I
actually refer to that I give you props
see possum in taters yeah that was the
hundredth at was the dish apparently it
was so people looking for long-lost soul
food recipes don't overlook the possum
so but tonight we're here to talk about
your latest book which I actually have
my security bag here the presidents
Cabot cabinet untold stories of African
Americans who have fed our families from
the Washington's to the Obamas and I
thought was interesting Adrienne that
you didn't you worked in the White House
and you said you didn't even you you
never went to the kitchen well no
because I'm the kind of dude that if I'm
not supposed to be someplace I'm not
gonna go and the White House is not a
place where you should wander around if
you you know don't need to be there but
I worked on something called the
president's initiative for one America
you probably have never heard of it but
it was an outgrowth of President
Clinton's initiative on race and here's
the wild and crazy idea about the
initiative on race if we actually talk
to one another and listened we might
find out that we have a lot more in
common than what supposedly divides us
so that was for that went on for about a
year and a half and then after that the
board that ran that including the late
John Hope Franklin recommended that
there be an ongoing office in the White
House to deal with racial reconciliation
and other racial issues so that was the
initiative for one America and so when
you when you got the idea to do this
book and you started the research which
how many years did you spend a long time
working so yeah this book was eight
years in the making and really what
inspired me to do it was unemployment so
at the change of an administration what
happens if you're at a political and
pointy and by the way the way I got the
job is the old-fashioned way I knew
someone so a friend of mine who was at
Georgetown Law School called me up while
I was practicing law in Denver and this
is not to disparage any attorneys in the
office but practicing law was just not
for me it got to the point where I was
singing spirituals in my office so I
figured I should use something else so
what in this funk while I was thinking
about opening up a soul food restaurant
in Denver she calls me and she explains
describes the president or the you know
initiative for one America and so I did
the same thing that Dick Cheney did when
George W Bush asked him to find a vice
president I was the head of the search
committee and only submitted my name so
you know so we get to the end of the
administration as an appointee what you
have to do is you write out your letter
of resignation
so shockingly George W Bush accepted my
resignation so I was unemployed the job
market was soft at that time I was
watching a lot of daytime television not
good not good so it was not the cheer so
I thought to myself I should read
something so I went to the book store
and I got a book on the history of
southern food written by the late John
Edgerton and that book was southern food
at home on the road in history and in
that book he said the tribute to achieve
african-american achievement in cookery
has yet to be written
so I just emailed him to see if somebody
had written that work because the book
was about 10 years old mm-hmm when I got
it and he said no one has really taken
on that project and so that led to the
my first book on the history of soul
food right and it was while I was
reading sources for that book that I
discovered these African Americans who
have cooked for our presidents including
something written by a Schomburg in the
1920s he was going to write a history of
African American cooking and he talks
about some of these presidential
Charitra Schomburg who found in the
Schomburg
yes we are in right now yes so one of
the earliest sources I got I came to
this library and found a photocopy of
something that he typed up because you
know there also if you dig into de bois
du Bois you say Dubois I save Dubois or
also I believe it's Booker T Washington
a lot of them actually did have a lot of
work related to food I know that de bois
does this whole extensive study on the
black caterers of Philadelphia and you
touch on that too the caterers of
Washington DC and how that was a pathway
of new money for for black people or
wealth and status and class that still
trickles in to today it's interesting
you said you know the no one had done
the piece about you know African
American accomplishments I mean is it
one piece there's you know you know
there's so much connection to America
food waste unlike any other what the
group arguably yeah and so you know and
and even this book oh my god you guys
this this book is it doesn't look that
thick but it is packed full with stories
and people and and dates I mean forty
four administration's all the different
people who are involved but there's so
many I mean this could be you could be
like another I don't know 50 books 50 I
don't know about that books written from
the stories in here right well the thing
about the African American presidential
history in terms of just the The Kooks
is it's a lot of it is fragments because
in the 18th and 19th centuries in even
into the 20th century the African
Americans were looked down upon right
and so servitude positions were just
something that African Americans were
born to do and so on a lot of the
historical sources in quotes quotes yeah
born to do so in a lot of historical
sources you only get references to Negro
cook or colored cook they didn't even
take the time to put out the person's
full name right so it's remarkable that
we see a person's full name and some of
these sources then when you get to 20th
century it's it's it's better yeah but
cooking was not the glamorous thing that
it is today it was one of the few
professions that African Americans could
pursue and excel at without garnering a
lot of white backlash mm-hm and we
that play out so in many ways what's
going on in the White House kitchen
mirrors what's happening in the broader
society absolutely and not just about
you know the there are place all of that
but also it's also very clear that they
are feeling our food yes and you know
and that they are even you talk about
times when white cooks have been fired
to rehire black cooks and so forth
so there's also a skill and talent
element to to this whole this whole lore
of of the mythical you know the amazing
black cooks I love how you set it up in
the beginning where you say how you know
there are cooks who are a couple you
call us scratch dump cooks right scratch
cooks who have more of an
improvisational approach and you know
let's see what's in my fridge or what's
in season and just kind of go with it
and then there are cooks that are what's
the French term that I'm going to put me
some pennies on plus he's on Plus right
which is so that means putting
everything in its place so if you're a
scratch cook and you're probably your
parents or somebody and your family's
like that you know they don't measure
and when you try to get a recipe they
have an attitude because you know they
know I don't measure so you have to just
watch them cook I'm one of those cooks
that I have to have everything kind of
set out so I know I have all my
ingredients and they're properly
measured and so what my approached in
terms of all the information yeah I
decided just to show all of the
ingredients the key ingredients to
presidential food ways the study of this
food culture and just so you know what
deals with the president directly
what involves people around the
president and then what are the things
beyond the president's control like
Congress or the public perception of the
president and just show how they all
kind of interact well that very
methodical approach yielded a very
detailed fact-based story filled piece
of work which is pretty phenomenal
everybody was like you don't have to be
the whole book just you know skim it and
just have a conversation I'm like no I
want to read this whole book it's really
fascinating I want to get a read